jean marc sylvestre bonjour alors on l'a
vu son budget il soulève beaucoup de
questions à commencer par sa crédibilité
compte tenu des incertitudes qui pèsent
sur la reprise de la pandémie
oui mais évidemment parce que nous
sommes fin septembre et nous allons
discuter d'un budget qui sera applicable
en 2021 sachant qu'on ne sait absolument
pas ce qui va se passer ne serait-ce que
dans trois semaines ou l'année prochaine
alors ce budget et c'est très important
il est construit sur une hypothèse de
croissance de 8% pour 2021 c'est lui
hypothèse de base c'est là c'est la
structure ça après une chute historique
de 10% en 2020
mais sachant que cette construction là
est menacée par trois phénomènes parce
que les 8% ils sont absolument pas gravé
dans le plomb trois phénomènes le
premier est ce son
c'est évidemment la crise sanitaire on
ne sait pas ce qui va se passer sur la
crise sanitaire ça peut déraper ça peut
entraîner des dépenses nouvelles
on le voit bien actuellement avec les
risques de ce rebond le deuxième
phénomène ce sont les effets de la
preuve excipe on n'avait pas prévu que
la prèv rexie tu ne déboucherait pas sur
un accord on a un accord de divorce qui
est très compliqué très difficile a
assigné avec les anglais et puis
troisièmement il ya des résultats de
l'élection américaine là c'est le
brouillard le plus total les trois
facteurs la peuvent encore tout
bouleverser alors si on suppose que ces
trois phénomènes ou n'auraient pas
d'aggraver de conséquence aggravantes et
bien le budget va effectivement porter
un plan de relance de l'économie de 100
milliards d'euros vous le disiez sans
augmentation d'impôts ce plan entraînera
donc un déficit de six points 7 % compte
tenu de toutes les dépenses courantes
ordinaires et extraordinaires liées à la
crise du coc vite d'où bien sûr un
engagement conséquent on va crever tout
l'état font la dette publique va donc
dépassé les 113% du pib
on est on est très loin des critères
européens à des critères de maastricht
mais je rappelle que ce relâchement a
été autorisée par bruxelles compte tenu
des circonstances exceptionnelles
l'allemagne d'ailleurs pour la première
fois de son histoire
beck elle aussi obligés de s'endetter
alors qu'ils vont être les gagnants et
les perdants
alors oui c'est toujours là la grande
question globalement en dehors
les plans de relance le total des
dépenses courantes va augmenter assez
modérément deux et demi pour cent ça
fait un budget quand même à 300
milliards d'euros
alors budget qui sortent gagnants
l'enseignement scolaire et plus
particulièrement les enseignants c'est à
dire des salaires des enseignants
environ 400 millions d'euros
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
eux ce sont les grands gagnants et puis
en deuxième en tout ce qui touche à à
l'écologie le développement et la
mobilité rurales là on sent bien que
l'on va un peu un geste supplémentaire
en direction des filets jaunes et puis
il ya le ministère de la justice a remis
sa justice lui va voir son budget
augmenter de 8%
c'est assez considérable mais c'est un
budget qui est quand même relativement
étroit et puis le ministère de
l'intérieur qui doit recruter dix mille
policiers de plus ça fait quand même
très longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
recruter des fonctionnaires aux missions
à l'intérieur vous avez aussi des
missions pour le travail l'emploi et la
culture
alors on a parlé des gagnants mais que
s'ils vont être les perdants alors on
n'en parle assez peu en général n'est
perdant mais les fonctionnaires de bercy
vont se sentir perdants parce que on ne
va pas beaucoup les caresser dans le
sens du poil les aides au logement
seront rabotées l'audiovisuel public
winn audiovisuel public et les anciens
combattants et alors ça va faire grogner
les régimes spéciaux de retraite la sava
grenier parce qu'ils auront du mal à
boucler leurs finances sans réforme vous
savez qu'il y à une réforme en cours
mais la partie la plus spectaculaire sur
budget c'est quand même regroupés dans
un plan de relance vous en parliez 100
milliards pour la réindustrialisation la
transition écologique et le soutien au
social je pense notamment au chômage
partiel c'est ce sont ces 100 milliards
là qui sont en risque de dérapage
compte tenu de l'aggravation de la
question c'est ce qu'on peut croire le
gouvernement quand il annonce qu'il n'y
aura pas d'augmentation d'impôts vous
savez les promesses n'engagent que ceux
qui les îles et qu'ils utilisent
entendent qui les reçoivent le budget
sera financée par de la dette
ça c'est sûr on l'a vu et une partie de
cette dette sera d'ailleurs européenne
puisque le plan de relance a été
finances sont financés par un emprunt
européen c'est d'ailleurs la première
fois qu'on mutualisent des bêtes au
niveau européen la priorité du
gouvernement non c'est de ne pas c'est
de ne pas faire l'impôt c'est la
priorité c'est de relancer l'économie
l'activité l'emploi et peut pas toucher
aux impôts
non il asphyxie ray le système on l'a
bien vu actuellement parce que on était
dans une phase de reprise économique est
là tout ce qui s'est passé avec la crise
sanitaire a encore cassé un peu le moral
des acteurs
alors il faut retrouver de la croissance
si on retrouve de la croissance est bien
on ne rate pas couvrir les recettes et
garantir les dettes alors si la
situation dérape compte tenu des risques
le gouvernement a quand même des
réserves
il a des réserves qui sont j'allais dire
quasi secrète très discrète ces réserves
sont constituées par les pagnes des
français le magot des français il est
considérable il faut que cette épargne
reviennent dans l'économie et est
actuellement scotché dans les comptes
courants de la caisse dépeinte dans les
comptes courants bancaires dans les
comptes à terme dans l'assurance vie
cette épargne actuellement n'est ni
investir ni consommer ça peut donner des
idées à l'écart par exemple pas écouter
vous savez l'état peut avoir l'idée
miracle
un matin d'organiser un grand emprunt
national
ça n'est qu'une idée on a déjà vu ça
dans l'histoire
merci jean marc sylvestre pour toutes
ces précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et chroniqueur économique